vraiment de balancer non seulement la
conversation
et donc la suivante alors
je fais le prince Charles et vous faites
Camille
je veux me sentir tout contre toi sur
toi de haut en bas dedans et dehors
[Rires]
voilà merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
je finirai en train de tourbillonner
perpétuellement dans la cuvette et ne
jamais disparaître
comment peut-on imaginer que ce soit
alors
[Rires]
incroyable
c'est un peu des conversations
il ira là-bas il ne sera pas arrêté par
par la police et donc ça veut quand même
dire que quand on est riche et puissant
on n'est pas jugé
les 70 ans
et c'est ce qui a été fait Charles
aujourd'hui dis-moi je ne sais pas du
tout qui était ce monsieur et le son
encore une fois à ressorti la photo
de l'Empire britannique et dans les
années qui ont suivi il
d'accord